yeah I think it's about that time so I'm
gonna get started hi I'm Tommy my day
job is that I'm actually a data
scientist here at Microsoft where I work
on really big experiments so a/b tests
on our online products you know millions
of millions of users in each side and
it's a lot of fun but that's not at all
what I'm here to talk about I'm actually
here to talk about about teaching data
science to two people that with a
program that I do through the University
of Washington so it's actually a joint
talk with with this guy Mako Hill who is
not here unfortunately we were double
booked this weekend so he's at something
else and I actually want to start with
the punchline so this graph was made by
someone who had 20 hours of programming
experience what she did is she went and
grabbed data from the internet she
processed sit with she grabbed it with
with an API in Python she processed it
to clean it up to remove you know some
noise some stuff like that and she made
this plot and what this is as you can
see is edits per day for all articles in
the Wikipedia category people shot dead
by law enforcement officers does anybody
want to guess what the what the spikes
are like is this No so that so the big
spike over there on the on the far side
that's like November of 2014 ish i
believe it was anybody anybody won't
know what that is so that was a Ferguson
right and and some of the others we
checked they are all sort of related to
a controversial events where someone was
shot by the police the sort of the next
big spike to the left was someone who
was actually shot dead on bart back in
2009 and all of these spikes are you
know sort of controversial events and
the magical thing here is this is
actually part of her research you know
this she's doing social science research
and she just needs access to like what
events moved the needle over the last 10
years and it turns out and this this is
sort of the thing that sort of people
like us are like i didn't know this was
a problem but if you just ask somebody
who sort of is interested in a problem
how do you go and get that kind of data
they don't often know it's hard to get
this stuff even though it's just there
if you ask and so that problem is why we
started a community data science
workshops which is a series of workshops
that we teach at the University of
Washington aimed at beginners and our
goal is to get them from very beginner
state to competent and capable of
answering the questions that they
already have in their day-to-day lives
and so the big reason we do this is
imagine a world and in fact this world
existed for quite some time we're only
some people control the access to
information only some people can read
only some people can write and they
they're sort of cloistered off somewhere
and then the the most people just don't
have access to reading and writing to
the things that sort of define the
modern world in a very real sense Mac
then having access to reading and
writing being able to do those things
having books it was sort of
automatically elevated you right in ways
that are that are that are sort of
profound it often lifted you from a very
short kind of miserable life right of
like you know tilling the land for
someone who is sort of who took all your
stuff to this elevated status and just
by knowing how to read and write and if
you think about it back then how do they
do this well there weren't very many
books and more importantly I think the
books that existed we're in Latin right
if you were in and you know what is now
France and you didn't and you sort of
spoke the vernacular whatever it was uh
you you couldn't even if you had a book
it wasn't going to be any good for you
because it wasn't even a language that
you may even know it turns out that
that's still true for people except for
now instead of of reading and writing in
a language the sort of the thing that
that is required increasingly required
to be successful in a modern world to
sort of have access to and understand
your world is data and and and on top of
data is computers and access to that
power in a very real sense determines or
at least partially determines
sort of how you go about your life and
it's not just the the economic
ramifications of this there's little
booklets out there that will tell you
that data scientists make more money
than average and sort of have more job
security than average and you know
there's and those are very real things
but there's also a social justice
component to this having access to the
means of producing and consuming data is
incredibly important just to to change
the world right to understand and
interact with what's around you but
we've we've sort of placed these
barriers in front of someone getting
started on that path one of the big ones
is where do you find the data right we
produce tons and tons of data on
Wikipedia on Twitter all these things
and we need to teach people to get that
data the other is and this is getting
better and a sort of weird way is the
arcane languages they're still there
used to be Latin for a while it was
something hard like see we've got things
like Python um but python is still
surprisingly sort of Vince you know
we're in this state now where we've got
so many buzzwords right like if you come
to this thing and you may think we're
going to zoo we're talking about like
snakes and pandas and stuff and it turns
out that that sort of barrier is very
real for people just understanding what
what words should i search on the
internet to solve my problem with a
computer is where is where we're meeting
people to get started so our goal is to
teach non-programmers to ask and answer
questions using python and data that
they can get on the web what i mean by
non-programmers unlike most boot camps
we have no interest in making
professional programmers being a
professional programmer is also i truly
enjoy it but that's not our goal in the
same way that not everyone needs to be a
professional journalist we do need those
but everyone needs to be able to reading
right right so we're aiming at that sort
of basic data literacy and so some of
the questions that we're enabling people
to ask an answer our new contributors to
an article on wikipedia sticking around
longer or contributing more than people
who joined last year so think about what
is required to answer a question like
that right you need to know it's easy to
look at wikipedia right and get one
article right
now how do you get the the historical
data of what have people edited in the
past for that article you know how do
you get the data on what does a single
user do and then you you can also you
know dive into Twitter data same thing
it's easy to read 40 tweets on twitter
com it's a little harder to read four
million tweets right but that's sort of
where the power comes from so how do we
do this our philosophy is to first of
all we actually we explicitly select for
absolute beginners unlike many of these
boot camps and and when I say select we
are almost always overbooked so we'll
usually get like 120 applicants and
except maybe maybe 90 and I'll talk
about that in a second that turns out
our rate limiting step is people like
you as mentors and then the other thing
is that we're again we're not making
programmers we're making problem solvers
we're prioritizing getting the answer
correctly and quickly over over anything
elegant or efficient the code that i
write at work and the code that i teach
them to write it turns out it is
different and that's okay teaching
someone to read and write you don't
start by saying you need to have
something you know that you can publish
right you you we don't we don't teach
that first we don't teach like setting
up a bibliography we teach getting your
point across in programming getting your
point across is getting the right answer
in a way that you understand and so
that's sort of teaching a subset of
Python the other thing we're doing we
have limited time it's three days is get
people as close to independence as we
can so what that really means is is a
few things number one teaching them
documentation and openness
reproducibility so in other words later
you're going to need to remember sort of
what we taught you and also you're going
to want to sort of show all of the the
steps and whatever it is that you've
discovered about the world so that
people can in check we've got this
philosophy that uh if something is is
documented open reproducible and wrong
that might actually be better than
getting the right answer in a way that
that you don't understand and that you
can't share with others because if it's
documented and open and wrong somebody
can at least correct you right this is
sort of
you know it's sort of the same thing
mind like open source software the other
thing that we do is is where we're sort
of emphatic that you should be able to
use the tools you already have right so
we're teaching you one of the best
things we can do for you is to get
Python running on your computer we
actually use anaconda for that get it
running on your computer as your
computer is now whether you know we
don't care about what OS you're adding
anything like that so that you have the
tools where you already use tools right
already on your computer and we also try
to interface with the tools you know
almost always that means excel so we're
completely fine you know we're not pure
a purist of like you should use
matplotlib no we want you to solve
problems solving problems is often use
Python for getting data from the web use
Python for cleaning that data use Excel
for visualization that's fine so some
other principles we have is that
students from the very beginning three
hours into learning what python is our
writing real programs on their computer
to solve actually real questions so
within three hours we give them a list
of all names of babies and that were
born in the United States and there's
some number of thousands of names which
is actually a really cool data set right
and so you can ask questions about like
well what are the popular names what
changes right what names change over
time um you can answer that immediately
with Python the other thing that we
really focus on is 521 learner to mentor
ratio again that's where you all come in
we can accept more people back for
everyone extra mint or we have we can
accept five more people right we
desperately need more mentors we already
have maybe 10 show up 15 show up and we
need quite a few more and and so in what
are you doing as a mentor you're
answering remember back when you learn
to program and you got those like arcane
error messages right like it prints a
stack trace you'd even know what that is
but it prints a bunch of stuff and what
really happened is you forgot to close a
quote yeah you're you're you're helping
people across that hump and that hump is
a lot bigger than you think it is now
right we're all I mean how many of you
are like professional programmers write
a lot of you right and so you're like
you probably don't remember
starting out right but that's where
we're that's where we're helping people
the other important point is we actually
look for mentors that just learn how to
program so if that's you or that someone
you know that's who we want because they
know what it feels like to sort of
struggle with your first program and
that's that's a sort of an important
thing that we often forget as
professionals so we actually teach for
sessions the most important one is the
first one we come in on a Friday night
and we have people set up anaconda
python on their computer and the reason
we do that is it sort of just works we
get so we they have Python running we
actually run them through a few small
exercises and Python so that they know
the very basics you know what a variable
is things like that we get a text editor
set up we get everything set up and the
reason that's important is you now have
the tools the tools can be very opaque
if someone says just go download Python
like where do you even where to even
start with that right now that you have
the tools we've enabled you to sort of
to sort of take your own destiny in your
hands we also this year we switched to
python 3 we know we had been to python 3
solved like all of our nasty issues we'd
had issues with if you ever just
installed Python on somebody else's
computer it turns out there's lots of
things that can go wrong the biggest one
for us was usually Unicode which is as
we all know sort of a disaster and so
Python 3 actually mostly mostly fixed
this if I can't believe last time we had
one person who still had a Unicode error
and it was because they had somehow
installed Python 2 after Python 3 and
their path was messed up so like Python
3 fixed it via Python 3 anaconda the
next session we start introducing
programming so within one day we go from
I know what python is because of
yesterday to writing loops using lists
using dictionaries using variables and
solving simple problems problems like
what's the most popular name of boys
last year in America you know what's the
what's the most popular name that is it
is used for both males and females you
know simple questions but but it's a
pretty good starting place so then week
two we usually have a break
week two we we introduce getting data
from the web what I love about that is
that it seems like this magic thing that
just download a ton of data from the
internet it turns out it's really easy
right we teach Python requests if you've
ever used python requests it's sort of
the simple way of downloading something
from the internet we within in the
afternoon we teach how to get data from
Twitter and how to get data from
Wikipedia we've also introduced the data
Seattle gov datasets if you've ever seen
these there they're pretty amazing so so
Seattle produces tons of data about the
city stuff like you know where are all
of the bike locks where can you lock up
a bike data sets that people actually
want right it can actually use to answer
real questions we introduced how do you
get that data from the internet and we
do it the way you guys learn how trial
and error right you tried some things
you've got error messages and you and
you look them up online and you fix them
and you sort of iterated until you've
got it right that's exactly what we
teach them to do and then we close or
the third session that is sort of
analysis and visualization of sort of
how do you how do you build a plot like
that one I showed you at the beginning
how do you how do you see your data so
throughout that mornings we're doing
interactive lectures and the afternoons
we're doing all projects either baby
names or or get data from Wikipedia and
Twitter or visualize something
throughout that we're focusing on some
of the sort of the data science
fundamentals thinking about things like
sampling like what are the blind spots
in your data right with Twitter this is
particularly important right if
anybody's ever use the Twitter data you
know you're sampling from a stream of
sort of unknown quality at an unknown
sampling rate you know with with with
sort of all these things that they're
not going to tell you about their data
that that this sort of can complicate
your analysis right oh you're probably
sampling in English for instance we sort
of cover those those gotchas right we
cover sort of how do you think about a
result that you might read and and I
think ideally coming out of that is
people sort of have that sort of
they're a bit incredulous right they
they don't believe things that they that
they read as much anymore because it's
so easy to get things wrong right they
you know we teach stuff like you know
see that correlation yeah that's not
real you know and and that's sort of to
get as part of literacy now right we're
inundated with these facts that suppose
it facts right that flow to us through
various things that we click on the
internet and learning how to filter that
and understand how would one actually
answer a question like like these people
claim they're answering it's incredibly
important to sort of survive in the
modern world as important is what we
teach are the words that we we never say
so you will never hear a say class
object method recursion list
comprehension especially list
comprehension we don't cover testing we
don't cover ipython notebook we we sort
of cover numpy only for plotting and
only if you want it right so we sort of
people sort of self-select into that I
would like to learn more of this versus
not why do we not teach this stuff it
seems kind of fundamental right the
reason is that it is fundamental at some
point but answering simple questions
getting started this is not where you
start right this is sort of teaching
someone to read by starting with the
bibliography you don't do that you start
with communicate solve the problem you
have and and so that's what we do this
by the way is Amelia she's a mentor she
knows what all those words mean so uh
yeah she does but but she's not teaching
them she's teaching people to solve the
problem they have so one sign of success
is that we're actually growing all these
other pictures I should say that are all
of like of super high quality oh by the
way that's Mako that's the other guy
that's not here all these super high
quality pictures are from friend of ours
this picture is from Waterloo we've
actually expanded so we've got three of
these run now in Seattle that's as close
to 300 people that have that have come
through and Waterloo ran one of these
what it was in Canada you can tell
because it's kind of kind of sad or
looking and and then there's also two
being planned in in Chicago in DC so
we're expanding all of our material is
is online wiki community day to see see
if you want to run one of these yourself
go for it all the data is there are
sorry all the data is there and also all
of the the material we teach is there
and and you're all you all know more
than you would need to know to teach to
teach this and more importantly if you
if you want to do this in Seattle will
probably teach again in in the fall we
usually try to so I'm probably half the
people are grad students at the u-dub
because we teach at the U dub and and
and quite honestly it's a sampling
problem right we we advertise so the
lists that we know about which all
happen to be at the u-dub so if you want
to help us publicize we'd love to have
that but we really do need mentors to
help us reach more people and you can
sign up at maaco at CC / that's a zero
so make out at CC / 0m it should
redirect you to some mailman mailing
list I can't emphasize this enough we
need people that are willing to dedicate
three weekends to help people and for
every person that we get as a mentor we
literally we have five new people that
we we could not teach before that we can
teach now so we you know we would we
would love love to have all of you yeah
so oh and you can find me if you have
questions down there um yes does it did
the link died oh it definitely don't see
see I will fix it in a second here sorry
about that go to the top link that one
definitely works I checked it I checked
that one and was like oh they both work
and that was a bad idea they worked for
you I think you might have typed it
wrong oh those were
oh oh oh I'll fix that my bad you can
tweet at me at all and remind me anyway
that's all I've got does anybody have
any questions
yeah we have a witness accessory right
here
yeah but I think the best sign we have
for that is that in the so we've taught
three of these in the latest one we had
two or three people come back as mentors
so that's like our best sign of success
right is we hope to we hope to
eventually retire from teaching and and
let the people that we've taught teach
other people so so yeah that's I think
that's the that's the goal we're not
under the illusion that we're going to
get everyone to that point right all we
can really do is innocence give you the
tools and teach you which words to put
into the internet right and the people
that are that are dedicated and they
really need it they they do quite well
it's so hard it is okay so that is the
hardest part and i think the advice is
you just have to be careful it's sort of
think through it practice helps a lot
they you probably have a friend who is
not a programmer at least one right try
it with them as is the answer yeah so
this is really is the hardest part is in
the way it happens is you're just like
programming along in front of them and
you do something that you're like oh no
I just open up a can like you
accidentally do it with this
comprehension it sounds silly to say
like you accidentally do that but you
totally will you'll accidentally do
something you like oh crap yeah that's
it's not yes and that people get
overwhelmed did you winter is that
what's that my phone is sorry uh alright
perfect oh good yeah okay huh I need to
correct that I bet i checked the first
10 anyway so to answer your question I
think the thing that is that has worked
for me is so first of all we're all on
some radiation of this is magic I don't
know where you are on that on that but I
know that mine is somewhere between like
you know like the OS and you know like
the language in the u.s. somewhere in
there it does sort of start becoming
magic and and part of programming is
dealing with abstractions that you don't
understand but you know the input and
output right and so we are in some sense
forcing them into the deep end but but
basically saying yes this library is
magic and the reason we're introducing
it is because you need a little magic
right now you know and that's how
programming works Python for instance is
basically just magic see and and so you
know yeah it's hard and I think the
hardest part for me when I'm doing it is
watching like the look of sort of panic
that comes over sometimes and the only
thing you can do is slow down a little
bit out them through explain that yeah
you know there are some things that I
don't really understand either for
instance how requests work like it does
things that I guarantee you it would
surprise me so yeah you just have to
sort of remember your audience I think
the people that typically almost the the
better you are at Python it's certainly
the more you use Python in your
day-to-day work it's almost inversely
correlated with being good at teaching
at this level
and so it's it's that's hard it's very
hard but it's also it does teach you to
think about the language in any way
that's a good question so how are we as
a society doing at teaching people this
sort of new literacy um I don't know of
a good metric I almost wonder if like
time in front of a screen as almost
correlated with it and the reason I say
well I don't know there's something
about like you know people like like
your grandmother that sort of came to
computers late in life still thinks of
them is more magic than you do even if
you were a layperson right um but in
general no I don't know that we have a
good metric yet you know I don't I don't
know and you know I think it's it might
be on us we have we have managed to make
a set of tools um that is very good for
power users and there's tons of people
out there working on sort of data tools
for not power users but the space is not
as well developed maybe is as you know
like the you come here and the things
that everybody wants to talk about our
spark and and things that that are three
levels up from from where people start
good so we'll in early because it's six
o'clock on Saturday